MARK: I'd like to
welcome you here
today for Michael Ruhlman,
who's going to be talking
about his book, "Grocery."
He's been a writer, a
chef, a gadget maker.
My connection with him was
through a food and cooking blog
a long time ago, and came across
some of the kitchen utensils
that he helped put
together and sell.
And then when I saw
his name come up
for a talk to come here,
and the topic of groceries
and the psychology behind them
and the mechanics behind them
and the history, it
all seemed fascinating,
because he comes at food
and cooking from sort
of oblique angles all the time.
So very glad to
have him here today.
And with that, Michael.
MICHAEL RUHLMAN:
Thank you, Mark.
Thanks to you for being here.
The spoon he was talking
about is called the--
I can't-- it's such a long
title, I've forgotten it.
MARK: It was the--
MICHAEL RUHLMAN: It's
the Bad Ass Perforated--
MARK: Oh, Bad Ass.
Yes.
MICHAEL RUHLMAN: The Bad Ass
Perforated AKA Egg Spoon.
MARK: Yes.
For making poached eggs.
MICHAEL RUHLMAN:
Because I didn't
like all the flyaway stuff in
eggs when you poach an egg.
And so there are many whites
that compose and different
proteins are composed
in egg white.
Some are thin, some
are viscous and thick.
If you let the thin
ones drip through,
you're left with this
beautiful viscous white
and it makes a
beautiful poached egg.
So that's the connection.
But we also have offset spoons,
because a friend of mine said,
Mike, I can make
anything you want.
I manufacture stuff.
And I had a spoon that
I'd bent for cooking.
So I made some offset spoons.
I made some flat
edge wooden spoons,
because I hate
round wooden spoons,
because round wooden
spoons are useless.
But that's all that I
see in people's kitchens.
So I try to make tools
that are not available
or things like that.
But mainly what I do is I write.
And I think that I've gotten
some popularity because
of my ranting and
shooting off at the mouth.
I started cooking.
I never meant to be here.
I was a journalist, copy
boy at the "New York
Times", when I got out of Duke
University, English major.
And I got a book contract
to go to the Culinary
Institute of America
to write about what
it meant to be a chef.
And I realized very
quickly that you
couldn't know what
it meant to be
a chef unless you became one.
I was dressed like a student.
I had my knife bags.
I was learning how to chop
and dice and everything.
And after three
weeks of basics, I--
we lived-- my then-wife and
our little baby daughter
lived 25 miles north of the
Culinary Institute of America.
And a big snow storm
hit the Hudson Valley.
And I couldn't make it in to
take the test-- the first test
of my career there, just
the basics, how to make
a bechamel sauce, how to chop.
And I really wanted to.
But I called the
chef, Mike Pardus,
37-year-old guy
from Connecticut,
but kind of a hard ass.
I called him.
And I said, Chef, I
can't make-- obviously,
the Hudson Valley is snowed
in, I can't make it in.
He said, OK.
I said, you don't
understand, Chef.
I really want to be there.
I'm taking this seriously.
And I would be there if I could.
But I can't.
He said, OK.
And I said, no, you
don't understand, Chef.
I really want to be there.
And I'd be there if I could.
But I can't.
He said, Michael, I'm
gonna stop you right there.
He said, what we're teaching
these kids here what
it means to be a chef
is not that you know how
to concasse a tomato or dice an
onion or make a bechamel sauce.
It's that when you're
a chef, you get there.
I said, well, Chef, I'd
get there if I could.
But I can't.
He said, that's fine, Michael.
You have your work.
We have ours.
We're chefs.
We get there.
We like it like that.
And he hung up the phone.
And my heart was thumping.
And I was pacing.
And I told my wife
what had happened.
And she said, so basically
he's calling you a wuss.
And I didn't really respond
to that, because I'm so upset.
And then she looked at
me and said, oh, you
are not driving 25
miles through a blizzard
to make a bechamel sauce.
I drove 25 miles
through a blizzard
to make a bechamel sauce.
And that changed my life.
Honestly, it changed my life.
We talk about cooking
from the heart.
We talk about
cooking out of love.
I learned to cook out of anger.
Chef Pardus had guilted me
into coming, had told me
that I couldn't do it.
I was furious.
I made it in.
Obviously I could.
I was lying to
myself, he told me.
And that's one thing you learn
when you're a really good cook.
You can't lie to yourself.
I was lying to myself.
I could make it in.
And I did make it in.
And from that day on.
I vowed to become a cook.
I wanted to become a cook.
So I learned how
to become a cook.
And I also was the
journalist that I needed
to be in order to write a book.
And I finished the Culinary,
and nine months later I
was working the grill station at
the best restaurant at the CIA.
And then I came home.
My then-wife looked
at me and said,
we're going to be
broke in four months.
You got to write this
book in four months.
And it took me--
you can't write a
book in four months.
I had written one book before
then on an unrelated subject.
And it took me eight
or nine months.
And you can't write a
book in four months.
But I didn't think
like that anymore,
because I'd gotten
there to the snowstorm.
When the chef says get
there, you get there.
Write a book in
four months, I'll
write a book in four months.
I went to my contract,
found out that I
had to write 90,000 words
to fulfill the contract.
I figured out that if I
wrote 1,400 words a day,
five days a week, taking
Saturday to revise, Sunday off,
I would have a book
in four months.
And I had a book in four months.
And so I used those
muscles as a chef
to fulfill my
obligations as a writer.
And I really think
everybody should
learn to be a chef
before they do anything.
We'd have a lot fewer excuses,
and we'd operate a lot more
effectively and efficiently.
That's kind of how
I got where I am.
Suddenly I was a
journalist, but then I
had something that almost
nobody, no other journalist
had, which was a foundation
in the culinary basics.
And through a fluke of luck,
after I finished the book,
I was broke.
I couldn't find another book.
I said, I'll get
a job as a cook.
I went out to the middle
of Ohio, this restaurant.
I knew this woman
was well-connected.
She could get me a job with
the best chef in Cleveland.
I could make a paycheck
and keep writing
about something I cared about,
which is food and cooking.
And she looked at my stuff.
And she said, oh,
my God, I'm working
with Thomas Keller
at the French Laundry
and we're looking for a
writer for our cookbook.
I was like-- at the time, Thomas
Keller was a god among cooks.
So I was a broke,
unemployed writer
who had no national
bylines or credentials
for writing about food.
I walk into a restaurant
in the middle of Ohio
called Stix, because it was
so far out in the sticks.
And I walk out with tickets
to the French Laundry
two weeks later.
That's God sort
of saying, I know
you want to be a
novelist, Michael,
but you're good at
writing about food.
You're going to
write about food.
And once I did that, once
I wrote "The French Laundry
Cookbook" with Thomas Keller,
I had fundamental knowledge
of the culinary fundamentals.
I had a knowledge of what
those fundamentals could do,
taken to the highest
level at then
considered the best restaurant
in the country, if not
the world.
Ruth Reichl, later that
year, would call it
the most exciting
restaurant in America.
And then I realized it's
important, writing about food.
I liked writing about food.
At the time, I didn't quite
realize it was important.
But as I continued
writing about it,
I thought other journalists
did better things,
did more important things.
They covered wars
and things like that.
They covered politics.
I was just writing about
bechamel sauce and veal stock.
Is that really important?
But as I kept writing and
as the country kept growing,
and I realized that
we were becoming
so obsessed with our food.
What does it mean?
What is it doing to us?
We're turning chefs
into celebrities.
What's going on here?
Food is important.
And I had sort of
lost track of that.
It was obvious to me
that food was important,
but I didn't quite
realize it until I
saw all the problems that were
happening because of our food
system and what we're doing
and that we'd stopped cooking.
Our healthcare system, it's a
billion-dollar-a-day problem
of diet-related diseases.
People have crazy allergies.
You have recent health problems.
These are not-- when
I was growing up,
I didn't know anybody
with a peanut allergy.
who was allergic to eggs.
Now there are kids--
So something is happening
to our food system.
And I realized that
this was important
and we need to consciously
acknowledge food is important.
Food is really important.
I think we've become
obsessed with food
because when something
you need to survive
starts making you sick, you
become very obsessive about it.
And it all sort of
crystallized for me,
and this book sort
of began when I
was standing in a grocery store
with dinner, some hamburger
buns and a bottle of wine and
some Lay's chips, I believe,
and some Greek yogurt,
and I was standing
behind a lady who was sort of
fortyish, dressed for business,
probably coming home from work,
grabbing some stuff for dinner
and the home.
And she put a carton of
fat-free half-and-half
on the conveyor belt.
And I looked at it.
I often wondered who buys
fat-free half-and-half?
Half-and-half is defined
by the amount of fat in it.
And so I couldn't help myself.
I asked this seemingly
intelligent woman,
excuse me, ma'am,
can I ask why you're
buying fat-free half-and-half?
And she looked at
me kind of puzzled
and said, because it's fat-free?
And I said, what do you think
they replace the fat with?
She'd never really
thought about it.
She'd picked it up
right there and read,
skim milk, corn syrup.
She looked at me, frowned, put
it back on the conveyor belt
and bought the fat-free
half-and-half anyway.
That moment sort of
crystallized a lot of things
for me, that we don't
think about our food,
that we allow other people
to do our thinking for us,
that we think fat is bad
is one example of that.
We're taught that fat is bad.
Fat is not bad.
Too much fat is bad.
Too much of anything is bad.
Lettuce.
I'm here to tell you,
lettuce is dangerous.
Lettuce can be hazardous
to your health.
If you only eat lettuce, you
will become malnourished,
you will become sick, and
women will become infertile.
So be very careful when
you're at that salad bar.
Same thing is true with fat.
If you eat too much fat,
if all you ate was fat,
that would be bad.
We need fat to dissolve
various vitamins.
It's good for us.
And it tastes good.
I'm just fond of saying, fat
isn't bad, stupid is bad.
We need to think more
clearly about food.
For this grocery book, I went
shopping with my physician.
And she picked up some
kale and she said,
it drives me crazy,
people call this healthy.
Kale isn't healthy, she said.
I said, it's not?
She says, no, kale's nutritious.
We are healthy.
Our food isn't healthy.
Our food is nutritious
or it's not nutritious.
We are healthy if we
eat nutritious food.
It begins with words.
Our understanding
begins with words.
We're not going to be able to
make good decisions about what
we buy, what we
feed our families,
what we cook, unless we
think clearly about food.
The second thing I think
people need to know
is, nobody really
knows anything.
All these studies drive
me absolutely bananas.
The fact that in
the '70s we were
told not to eat eggs,
because they were bad for us.
Cholesterol in the
yolks, obviously they're
going to make our blood
serum cholesterol go up.
We were told for
more than a decade
that the egg, this miracle
of economy, nutrition,
deliciousness, and functionality
in the kitchen, was bad for us.
Food for humans for
millennia, bad for us.
Not true.
Further investigation, what
the actual studies now show
is that if you have
low cholesterol,
eggs actually will
raise your cholesterol.
If you have high
cholesterol, eggs
don't affect your cholesterol.
That seems to be what
the studies show.
So the eggs are helping
you find the right balance
for your cholesterol.
Again, people say, well,
how do I know what to eat?
What do I eat?
What I tell all
people how to eat
is, don't pay attention
to how something tastes
or how you feel while
you're eating it.
Pay attention to how you
feel after you eat it.
I love Pringles potato chips,
one of the most heavily
processed foods on the planet.
It's delicate, crispy,
tastes vaguely like potato.
Salty.
I love those things.
But if I eat a whole tube
of them, I feel shitty.
But if I eat a buttered steak
with a nice crust of salt
on it, a baked potato with
a slab of butter on it,
and some green
beans, I eat that,
and I feel good afterwards.
That's my body saying,
yeah, that's nutritious.
And here's the
thing with the word.
Now, you look at that plate,
and you see all the butter,
and you see salt and stuff.
And if I were to ask
somebody, is this healthy?
Is this plate of food healthy?
It's harder to answer.
But if you say, is
this food nutritious?
That's much easier to say,
yeah, you've got a good protein
there-- sorry for
the vegans here--
you've got a good fat--
dairy fat, sorry.
Vegan is hard.
I don't know about how
I would live as a vegan.
Not that I am against
it for any reason.
I respect your
reason to be a vegan.
It's just hard.
It's hard and unpleasant.
And there's so much pleasure
to be had in cheese and butter
and things like that.
I think it's easier
to think about food
if we think of it in proper
terms with the proper words.
And so this is just what I do.
I write about food.
I write about these issues.
And I try to make
sense of things.
And my father loved
grocery stores.
He would go to five different
grocery stores in a day.
Loved them.
They were sort of bounty itself.
You could get so much cool food.
But for him, it was like frozen
appetizers in the frozen food
store.
But he loved grocery stores.
He loved going.
He loved looking at
other people's baskets.
Wonder what they have.
They've got something
better than I have.
And he once said to me,
you know, when I retire,
I think I might bag groceries.
When he died in 2008, I was
bereft and upset and depressed.
And I think that's part of
why I went a few months later
to a small grocery
store in Cleveland, Ohio
to look into where we
buy most of our food.
Grocery stores were
interesting to me.
They're a retail store that
we use like no other store.
It's the only store most of
us have to go to once or twice
a week.
They are a symbol.
And during the
Cold War, they were
a symbol of American
capitalism and prosperity.
They're a mirror of our culture.
They show what we're
afraid of, what
we're curious about, what we
don't know, what we crave,
shows you how big we are.
This one store I went--
so I went up to Heinen's.
It's sort of like a Wegmans.
I don't know.
What's a good quality
grocery store here?
I don't know them up
in San Francisco area.
MARK: [INAUDIBLE]
MICHAEL RUHLMAN: Anyway, this
is sort of a high end grocery
store.
They had about 20 stores.
And during that first
meeting with the brothers,
I learned that this one
store did $600 million
in sales yearly.
This was more than a half
a billion dollars a year
in sales.
And yet, they only made a $6
million profit every year.
A 1% profit, which is a really
scary margin to work on.
And yet they're
responsible for our food.
One of the things
I want to know is,
how can I get pea pods 365
days a year, as much as I want?
And not just in the
Heinen's stores--
any of their 20 stores--
but in the 100 stores around
Cleveland, and at the 38,000
grocery stores in America.
Where was all this
food coming from?
Where did it come from?
And that's why I wanted to
look into grocery stores.
And I realized ultimately how
much I loved grocery stores.
Most people think of them as
chores or sort of a headache
or someplace you have to go
to endure-- get in, get out.
I began to see grocery stores
as a remarkable institution
in America, a place where
we get all kinds of food--
both nourishing and crummy
food, but that's up to us--
all kinds of food for
relatively inexpensive--
at an inexpensive cost.
It's extraordinary that
we have so much food.
And I think that we need
to appreciate the food.
So that's all I did.
I hung out at grocery stores.
I bagged groceries.
And it was amazing to watch
the river of food come down,
just an endless river of
food, an extraordinary volume
of food.
This one store, for instance,
brings in every year
32,000 pounds of carrots, week
after week, year after year.
And what's, I think, even
more astonishing than that,
if you extrapolate that 20
stores does about 30,000 pounds
of carrots a week.
Multiply that by 32,000
or 38,000 stores.
That's a lot of carrots
that we go through.
And they're all mainly grown
in one place, Bakersfield,
California.
About 90%, 95% of
our carrots come
from Bakersfield, California
and in fields so vast
they have to fly to them.
That's how much room it takes.
So all these issues
just came into focus
when I started looking
into the grocery store.
And I think it's important,
because cooking--
it's ultimately important
because cooking is important.
I'm going to talk for five
more minutes about why
cooking is important and
related to the grocery store.
And then I hope to have some
sort of dialogue about what
matters to you about food.
But for me, cooking is more
important than we realize.
There's a great book
called "Catching Fire:
How Cooking Made us Human."
Do any of you know that book?
It's by-- do you know it?
Have you heard of it?
It's by Richard Wrangham,
a primatologist at Harvard.
And he argues
persuasively in this book
that it wasn't the
taming of fire that
made us triumph as a species.
It wasn't a genetic
fluke that tripped us
over from our hominid
ancestors to Homo sapiens.
It was the cooking of food.
At the time, there
about 12 upright
different species, different
versions of this animal
that we have become.
We began cooking
food, at some point.
And it changed us.
Once we cooked food--
before we cooked food,
we had to sit in one place
by ourselves masticating
pounds and pounds
of raw vegetation
in order to get enough
calories to support
this big body of ours and this
calorie-hungry brain of ours,
which uses about 30% of our
calories that we take in.
Once we started
cooking food, we could
consume extraordinary
amounts of calories
very quickly and
very efficiently.
This made us very healthy.
It allowed us to
spread our genes.
It changed our anatomy.
Our gut shrank,
because we didn't
need to fill it up with
massive amounts of vegetation.
Because we weren't shoving
pounds of vegetation down
our throats, it
conceivably allowed
us to develop a more delicate,
refined vocal anatomy that
allowed for nuanced language
instead of sign language,
which we likely were
using at the time.
And it did something
else really important.
In order to take advantage
of the genetic advantages,
the health advantages of cooked
food, we had to work together.
Cooking takes work.
We had to work together.
Someone had to stay at
home and cook the tubers
while the men went out and
looked for the high protein
items, which were hard to get
and often were hard to come by.
We would then share.
We shared in the work.
We shared in the eating.
You couldn't be an
asshole anymore,
because you wouldn't
get any food.
You'd be ostracized
from the group.
So we learned to cooperate.
And arguably, sitting
around eating this food,
we learned to talk together
and to work together.
And this allowed
us to cooperate,
and arguably allowed us to
protect ourselves, strategize,
and ultimately become the
most successful species
on the planet
because of cooking.
Move forward to the
1950s and 1960s,
when we largely stopped
cooking our own food.
And that is precisely when
our health concerns begin.
It's when social alienation
begins to be documented.
And it's the beginning of
all our health problems.
So when I question whether
the veracity of that
claim that cooking
made us human,
I look at what happens
when we don't cook
and I look at all the
problems that there are today.
And that's why I think
that cooking is important.
That's why I think
it's important to know
what's in your grocery store.
And that's why I
will write that, as I
did in "The Washington
Post," which I think
will come out tomorrow,
that things like breakfast
is the most dangerous
meal of the day,
because 90% of our
households rely on cereal,
which is basically sugar.
And it's not just the sugar.
It's the refined
wheat that it's made
from that becomes sugar
pretty much as soon as it
enters your bloodstream.
We need to think
about these things,
because if we're not
healthy, we're not happy.
And if we're not healthy, we
don't have healthy families.
So ultimately, a
book about groceries
is a book about the importance
of cooking and my conviction
that when we cook our
own food, our bodies
are healthier, our
families are healthier,
our communities are healthier,
and our environment is
healthier, all of which are
fundamental to our happiness.
And so that's why I wrote
"Grocery," basically,
to look into where
our food comes from.
And thanks for
listening to me spiel.
I'd rather have a conversation
and talk about things
that matter to you guys
and answer questions
as to why you're
here and what you
care about regarding our
food system or just the food
that we eat.
Because the center
of the grocery
store is nutritionally
bankrupt, by and large.
The periphery, we
know, is good for us.
All the stuff that goes
bad is good for us.
The way they make
food shelf-stable
so it can sit on
the middle shelves
is to take out all
the nutrition in it.
The nutrition is what goes bad.
So if your food doesn't
go bad, you probably
should think twice
about eating it.
Those Pringles that
I love so much?
They'll be good for two,
three, four, five years.
That's not good.
So are there any questions,
any topic somebody
wants to talk about?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: I want to know
more about your involvement
with the group of
investors who are
trying to take over Whole
Foods, or influence it somehow.
MICHAEL RUHLMAN: Well, I have
nothing to do with Whole Foods
personally.
So nothing between
me and Whole Foods.
Whole Foods is a really
interesting story right now.
Whole Foods really changed--
if there was one person who
really changed our food system,
it's probably John Mackey, who
is the founder of Whole Foods.
He, more than anybody
else, convinced farmers
that they could make a living
by growing organic food.
Most of the grocers
I talked with
say supermarkets didn't not
want to carry organic food,
because people wanted it,
they started wanting it.
We couldn't get
enough of it, they
said, until Whole
Foods came along.
They went national in 1988.
And that's really when
organic became viable.
They convinced enough cattle
growers and meat packers
to grow their beef without
hormones and antibiotics.
This made it possible for
normal grocery stores that
didn't have the buying
leverage that Whole Foods had
to buy hormone-free beef,
beef that's better for us.
And that leads to
their problem now.
They were so good
at what they did,
they created so
much of this food,
that it's now available
to all the grocers.
So all the grocers have
just what Whole Foods has.
And now the only thing that
distinguishes Whole Foods
from a grocery store
is higher prices.
And so that's why
they're in trouble.
And that's why they're
creating this 365 chain, which
is basically just a
grocery store now.
So that's what's happening
with Whole Foods.
And I don't know what's
going to happen to them.
They want a big investor
because they're in trouble.
The downside is that we could
see the demise of Whole Foods.
The upside is we can
get that same stuff
at our local
supermarket these days.
So that's what's up
between me and Whole Foods.
AUDIENCE: Sorry.
I read something more
specific, that you
were involved with a
specific group of investors
who are trying to get
on the board and--
MICHAEL RUHLMAN: No.
AUDIENCE: No?
OK.
MICHAEL RUHLMAN: No.
I'm a writer and
journalist and I am not
associated with any investors.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: As I mentioned, I had
some health issues recently.
And I did a lot of research
about what I should and should
not eat.
And I came to the
conclusion that I
should stop eating refined
sugar and refined wheat.
And you briefly mentioned that.
But I love bread.
And I did a lot of
research and found out
sourdough is OK to eat.
Do you have some insight
to share on that topic?
MICHAEL RUHLMAN: Yeah.
I wouldn't listen
to anybody when
they make nutrition claims,
because nobody knows what
the fuck they're talking about.
Bottom line.
There haven't been the double
blind long-term studies
necessary for any definitive
conclusions about what's
good for us, what's bad for us.
There are some certain
common sense things.
And there is more
and more evidence--
and this does make common
sense, and it's my personal bias
and my opinion only--
that it is sugar and
refined grains that
are causing the
majority of problems,
largely related to
the insulin release
that happens when either these
refined grains or sugar come
into your bloodstream.
You get too much sugar, it
triggers an insulin response.
There's not enough insulin
to deliver this energy
to where it ought to go.
And so it's stored
as fat and creates
all kinds of other problems.
So yeah, I would agree.
And the nutritionist doctor
that I spoke with always
advise her clients, stay
away from stripped carbs.
Here's another-- I was
talking about words.
She says they're stripped carbs.
We talk about refined wheat?
Refined has good connotations.
It's pure.
It's refined.
It's not refined.
It's stripped of its nutrients.
That's what it is.
So she wants us to think
of not refined wheat,
but stripped wheat,
stripped of its nutrients.
Fortified.
We have to fortify--
fortify is good.
Well, we have to fortify
stuff because we took
all the good stuff out of it.
So we got to try and
put it back in there.
I think your suspicions are
right about refined wheat
and grain, especially
in the morning,
ironically, when there's
no fat, there's no fiber,
there's no protein that slows
the absorption by your blood.
So I don't want
to give up pasta.
I love bread, too.
What I think you need to do
is not be afraid of bread,
but eat good bread.
Eat good sourdough.
Eat foods that still
have a fiber matrix.
Corn flakes don't
have any fiber.
All the fiber has been
taken out of them.
That's the stuff that
slows its absorption
into your bloodstream.
So have bread, but have some
protein with it, as well.
Have some fat with it, as well.
Don't just eat pure bread.
I wouldn't just have a bowl
of pasta with some oil on it.
I'd have other things, too.
So minimize that sugar.
Try to eat as little as
possible before noon.
This is what that
doctor recommended.
Seems to make sense.
By then, you're
ingesting other stuff
to slow the absorption of
the refined wheats and sugars
that we eat.
But I would agree, yeah,
stay away from sugar
and stay away from
refined grains.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
MICHAEL RUHLMAN: Hi.
AUDIENCE: I haven't
read the book.
I'm excited to do so.
MICHAEL RUHLMAN:
It's just out today.
So there's no way you
could have really read it.
AUDIENCE: It's 3:00.
It's Google.
MICHAEL RUHLMAN: That's true.
You've had plenty of time.
AUDIENCE: But I'm
wondering, do you touch on
in the book anything about
food distribution systems
and issues with monoculture and
diversity of product in stores,
and food miles and all
those sorts of issues?
MICHAEL RUHLMAN: I
don't get heavily
into that, because I've found
that stuff, while important,
it's really boring.
And it's hard to write
an interesting narrative
about that.
It is important.
Tho other part of that equation
is it's incredibly complex.
The issues of monocultures
is a serious one.
If we rely on
monocultures, we are
jeopardizing our food system.
And we can't.
If we allow Roundup and
Monsanto, these companies
to develop products for
us, we're in danger.
Is it a good thing that
we now can get blueberries
from Uruguay in the winter when
we never used to be able to?
Well, it's good for
those farmers in Uruguay.
Is it bad for the food miles?
Cargill will tell you one
thing and farmers here
will tell you another.
And both have their points.
It's a very complicated system.
And it was outside the
purview of the book.
I talk about what I
don't write in the book,
because I felt so overwhelmed.
This whole grocery store
represented our entire food
system.
And it was so complex
and so baffling
that I had to pick and
choose where I went.
But those issues are important.
We're dealing with
them every day.
And I don't have
the answers to is it
a good thing that we
can get blueberries
from Uruguay or strawberries
from Chile in January.
My son says that it's
probably a bad thing.
But we set up a system, we set
up expectations here in America
that we can get anything
we want whenever we want.
And until we stop demanding
fruit that's out of season,
we're going to keep getting it.
Because that's one thing
I do know that when
you buy something at a store,
or if you take something
off the shelf, you are
asking for more of it.
It will be replaced.
That's their job.
So when you buy a
can of Pringles,
they're going to put it back.
If no one bought Pringles
anymore, they'd disappear.
We've seen our grocery
stores go from selling--
the only herb I knew when I
was growing up was parsley.
Now we have a whole
range of herbs.
We have all kinds of
fruits and vegetables,
just because we want it.
We've created really good
food in our grocery stores
just by demanding it.
So I guess the only thing that
I would say to you is if you
believe in multi-cultures--
not monocultures--
buy those foods that encourage
the creation of a diverse crop.
Don't buy monocultural products
and they won't come back.
AUDIENCE: So one thing
that I've noticed
is that you can get a
diversity of product
in cities, in places
where people are demanding
the diversity of product.
But then it is probably
flown in from all sorts
of different places where
they grow that diversity.
But if you actually
go out closer
to where food is grown in
this country, or the middle
of America or just
outside of cities,
that the diversity of product
is much lower because of the way
that the distribution
system is set up.
And if anything, it seems
odd that the food probably
didn't travel from down the
road, where it might have been
grown, but from
some other place,
like you're saying, like the
blueberries from Uruguay.
Anyway.
Look forward to
reading the book.
MICHAEL RUHLMAN: Thank you.
It's a tough problem.
And I'd be grumpy if I
couldn't have coffee,
because I don't live in
an area that grows coffee,
or get olive oil.
It's a big world, and we
have a lot of opportunity.
And we never even thought
about these before.
But these are
issues that we need
to think more and more about.
And there are no good
answers right now.
AUDIENCE: What
does it really mean
when we say a food is organic?
Is there a
certification process?
When I see a food in the
store and it says "organic",
what does it actually mean?
MICHAEL RUHLMAN: It
means it is certified
by the government as organic.
Any farmer that wants to
call his or her food organic
is certified by the government.
And it costs a lot of
money to get it certified.
So it is certified.
There's various rules
that they're looked at.
There are no pesticides
and all that.
And so it is organic.
Has organic then been
co-opted by big business?
In many ways, it has.
Is organic even better?
We don't know, but we
suspect that it is.
All the pesticides, especially--
there's a number of pesticides,
but one I look at is
glyphosate, which is in
the chemical Roundup--
that seems to actually--
doesn't affect our
health, per se, but it
really screws with our gut
bacteria, which we really need.
We have more bacteria
in our systems
than we have actual cells.
That's how much
bacteria we have.
And so I think that organic
food is a better choice,
regardless of it's big
business organic or not.
And remember that just because
something isn't called organic,
it may be just as
good as organic,
because that farmer is small
and doesn't want to pay
for an expensive certification.
And that's too bad.
We need to recognize
what's meaningful
organic, what's not
meaningful organic, what's
almost organic, or just as
good as organic, as well.
But to answer your
question, it's
certified by the government
as being pesticide-free.
And there's a whole
range of qualifications.
But it is all organic.
Often, you can get organic
stuff in the normal produce.
If they run out of something
in your grocery store,
they'll just put the organic
and not even label it organic.
But anything labeled organic
must be organic and certified
as such.
AUDIENCE: So unquestionably,
one of the reasons
that people are pushing
more towards processed foods
and more towards these really
quick, ready-to-eat foods
is that they're fast.
It's instantly available.
I grab it off the shelf.
Like you said, it can
last forever, seemingly.
So how do we make better
foods more convenient?
MICHAEL RUHLMAN:
I don't think we
can make them any more
convenient than we already
have.
They're pretty convenient.
I mean, is three minutes in the
microwave not convenient enough
for you?
I mean, it used to be 30
minutes of a frozen pot
pie in the oven.
And that became too long.
Then nine minutes in the
microwave was too long.
So they said,
let's get it lower.
I think the problem is
in the way we think.
The problem's with us.
Yeah, we want convenience
and we want cheap.
One of the food researchers,
food marketing researcher
I talked with, said,
our food is never
going to change because we
are cheap and we are lazy.
And we're always
going to be that way.
So any food that saves us
time or saves us money,
it's going to keep coming back.
That's going to be your fad.
In fact, it's not even
if it saves us money.
Because I can always
make more money.
I can't make more time.
So it's got to save me time.
This is the wrong
message, I think.
What we need to realize, what
people need to understand,
is that the cooking of
food should take more time.
We have to re-evaluate
how we spend our time.
The food companies
said they were
going to make our lives
easier, more convenient,
better by cooking
our food for us.
Has it gotten better?
Are we healthier?
Do we have more time?
No.
We have even less time.
Our food, it couldn't
be more convenient.
We have even less time.
So what's going on here?
We need to re-think about
how we allocate our time
and recognize that
spending time shopping,
cooking, sharing that
cooking with our friends
and our family, and cleaning
up afterwards is valuable.
You don't hear anyone saying,
I really love showering,
I just can't find the time.
No one says that.
We find the time to bathe.
We find the time
to do what we like.
We find the time to watch TV.
Some of us even read still.
I hope so.
It's a matter of recognizing
that the smells of cooking
in a house are stress-relieving.
They relax us.
Food brings us together
and makes our lives better.
So it's a matter of recognizing
the importance of cooking
and what we give up when we
just put things in a microwave.
Convenience is not
a real convenience.
And cheapness is a lot more
expensive than we realize.
So it's a way we think
about food and cooking.
And that's mainly
what I care about
and what I try and preach.
And it's preaching, I agree.
But I think it's important.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: In the
book, you go back
to the genesis of
groceries as raw materials
that you did have to take a
lot of time to process or shell
or soak or whatnot.
But to some extent, I think
you can buy time today
by getting pre-cut vegetables
and things like that
and saving on the prep time.
But you're still
doing the cooking.
And I'm curious,
because I think you
have a chapter in
there, which is, people
don't know how to cook anymore.
And they buy arguably nutritious
meals prepared at groceries
now.
But are you seeing
that other part,
which is you take a step back,
which is you still go home
and you cook.
And there's all different
kinds of online services
now that you can get
someone else to be
your prep chef for you, right?
MICHAEL RUHLMAN: Right.
AUDIENCE: Are you
seeing more of a trend
like that to sort of shorten
things in terms of time.
So buying time and yet
still doing cooking at home?
MICHAEL RUHLMAN: Yes.
Certainly we are finding
that that we want to cook,
we just don't want
to do all the work,
so we're gonna pay someone
else to do it for us.
There was a lot of talk
about growing our own food.
Some people really do
grow their own food.
Bless you for doing that.
I think it's great.
But for the most part, we didn't
start growing our own food.
What we did was we started
supporting farmers' markets.
We paid other people
to do it for us.
Now we're getting people
to do our prep for us.
We're getting Blue
Apron and Hello
Fresh to do our prep for us.
We're buying pre-chopped
onions at the grocery
store, which I think is fine.
I think that's fine.
I think if more people
used Fresh Direct--
not Fresh Direct, Blue
Apron or Hello Fresh,
they're gonna realize how
easy cooking really is.
They say, oh, my God.
That was so easy.
I know how to get two scallions
together and a clove of garlic
and a protein here.
And we'll go back to cooking.
They may teach us
how to cook again.
Maybe that's how we
learn to cook again.
The comment about nobody
knows how to crook
came from the woman who did the
prepared foods at the store.
She said, I'm just astonished.
Women don't know
how to hold knife.
Nobody knows how
to cook anymore.
And it's possible that a
huge swath of our population,
because our food
was prepared for us,
never learned how to cook.
And that's scary.
So we need to
re-learn how to cook.
And I hope places like Blue
Apron help us to do it.
It is getting more
and more popular.
And I would say, because
it saves us time,
if those companies like
Blue Apron can make money--
I don't think
they're making money
yet-- if they can
make money, they're
going to stick around, because
they're saving us time,
and they're helping
us eat better
food and nutritious food.
So I'm all for that.
Well, thank you very
much for being here.
Cook your own food.
It makes life better.
Thanks for listening to
me on my soapbox here.
I appreciate it.
MARK: Thanks so much.
MICHAEL RUHLMAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]